One more.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
He was
[Silence]
alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the chapter of patience authored by
the first narration he mentions
is a very critical narration in the
sense that it gives us many fundamentals
upon which various sciences of Islam are
founded.
This narration has been cited by many of
scholars of Islam as one of the miracles
of the prophet sallall.aii
which he referred to as
he said
that one of his miracles that he was
given that the prophets before him were
not was that he was given the most
concise yet most broad and expansive in
meaning
words of revelation.
So, we'll have just a sentence or a few
words. Yet, because of the way that
those words fit together with the rest
of the revelation of the Quran and
Sunnah, those few words have an
incredibly extensive meaning to them.
This narration is one of them. He gives
us foundations
upon which many of the various forms of
worship in Islam are built and a core
description for each.
he mentions this narration
in one of his books that is very well
known
which is the 40 narrations.
That book he wrote which he gathered in
it 42 narrations of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam upon which all of
the rest of the Quran and Sunnah are
built. Those are the 42 core narrations
of the sunnah. He's referred to them as
the 40 narrations because they're
roughly 40. and this narration is one
of them because of how expansive its
meanings are. Yesterday we discussed the
first sentence which was
purification
is half of eman.
The second
statement that he makes
and third which have to do with the with
he says
Alhamdulillah
fills the scale.
The scale of what? The scale of good
deeds.
The scale of good deeds are filled with
alhamdulillah
figuratively and literally.
alhamdulillah fills the scales
meaning that everything a person does it
comes from a place of alhamdulillah in
their worship of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala when a person stands to pray that
prayer is saying alhamdulillah
meaning the state that a person is in
the act of worship they give something
for the sake of Allah that giving is
saying alhamdulillah
etc. Alhamdulillah is the basis upon
which all acts of worship are built. Why
is that? What is alham what is
alhamdulillah?
Often times we take a translation for
instance of a word a common phrase and
we stop there and we don't really think
beyond that or we take it kind of for
granted. What does alhamdulillah mean?
Well, many people would say
alhamdulillah means praise.
Praise. All praise is for Allah. Great.
What is praise? What does that mean?
What is all praises to Allah? What is it
that is to Allah?
The scholars of Islam tell us that
alhamd and in Arabic often times a
person you would say what is alham you
might get an answer like
[Silence]
And so we see here that
what is its exact definition?
Alhamdulillah.
Alhamd
is describing
the one being praised
with love and exaltation
while describing with the tongue with
thee
descriptions of perfection. Meaning
that a person describes. So for instance
we say alhamdulillah. What is that? It
is describing Allah with all perfection.
Ascribing to him all perfection
whilst the heart is filled with love and
exaltation. This is referred to as
alhamdas.
Subhan Allah
is the opposite.
What is Subhan Allah? Often times the
translation will say subhan Allah, glory
be to Allah. What does that mean?
Subhan Allah
as alhammed is affirming for Allah.
Affirming for Allah all perfection, all
aspects of perfection. When I say
alhamdulillah,
I am saying all perfection, all names,
attributes, descriptions of perfection
belong to Allah. That's what
alhamdulillah means. And this is only
considered ham when I have a heart
filled with love and exaltation.
So when I say alhamdulillah
I am saying oh Allah
to you belongs all descriptions of
perfection.
You are complete in every way.
What is subhan allah? Subhan Allah is
the opposite. It is negating.
So whereas alham is affirming for Allah
all perfection,
subhan is negating
all imperfection from Allah. So when I
say subhan Allah, I am saying, "Oh
Allah, you are free of any imperfection.
No matter how minor or slight,
no imperfection belongs to you.
You are perfect in every way and
imperfect in no way. When you say subhan
Allah alhamdulillah together and that's
why they often come together in the I
say subhan Allah
subhan Allah
I am saying subhan Allah. Oh Allah,
there is no sort of imperfection that is
ascribed to you.
You are
free of any imperfection. Then I say
alhamdulillah.
Then I affirm the second half which is
and to you belongs every kind of
perfection.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasallam said
and this is the last narration alkari
mentioned in his
the first narration he mentioned
deeds are bought by intentions. The last
narration he mentions in his
subhan all
subhan allah
he says two statements which are very
light upon the tongue very heavy in the
scales very beloved to alman
subhan allah
oh Allah
You are imperfect in no way and perfect
in every way. That is what subhan all he
means.
Subhanahu wa'talamu.